toutes les générations sont rassemblés
devant cet hôtel de coignières les
bénévoles de l'association élan
courtoise les frères d'argile propose
aux locataires de cet hôtel des migrants
de rompre le jeûne du ramadan dans notre
communauté on se doit de faire ça donc
on est beaucoup dans les chances dans le
partage
et voilà donc on se rend compte que
malgré les les kilomètres qu'ils ont pu
faire ça reste on a les mêmes pratiques
on a la même façon de penser de par note
votre religion et voilà donc on se
retrouve entièrement dans tout ce qu'on
fait ramadan soit c'est c'est un mois
dans lequel il faut se priver
il faut se mettre à la place des plus
démunis de ceux qui ont pas tous la
chance qu'on a justement de manger ce
qu'on veut de boire quand on veut et
et le fait de partager sa de couper le
ramadan avec des personnes justement
qu'ils qui n'ont pas les moyens qui
peuvent pas manger à leur faim je trouve
que c'est c'est juste parfait
c'est juste très bien le ramadan ou un
sacré est l'un des cinq piliers de
l'islam comme ibrahima migrants maliens
arrivé en france en 2014
ils sont 150 migrants à rompre le jeûne
chaque soir avec l'association machaal
mois s'appelle longtemps vraiment et on
n'a pas eu
elle n'a pas eu la sensation qu'ils
viennent nous aider a paru vraiment les
remercie pour tout ce dont ils font pour
nous est vraiment et on les encourage
on ne veut pas que ça reste comme ça on
souhaite que ça continue ça me touche au
coeur vraiment difficile on est tous des
frères donc nous ont montré que vraiment
nous aussi il n'y a pas deux appels qui
sont de couleur nous ont montré que
vraiment et on est tous des musulmans et
que à moi charles live merci moi aussi
c'est ce que l'on recherche
l'association propose aussi des colis
alimentaires à des familles
saint-quentinoise le ramadan 2016
prendra fin le 5 juillet prochain